-Thanks to newly developed
technology,
we here at "Late Night" now have
the ability to record
the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that,
like everyone's inner voice --
and we all have them --
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
So here it is, the tiny voice
in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪
-Hey, Donald. It's the tiny
voice in the back of your head.
And I'm letting you know that
your greatest fear is true --
no one likes or respects you.
The two world leaders
you're standing between
are embarrassed to be on stage
with you right now.
As soon as this is over,
they're going to go to dinner
and talk about you.
They're going to talk
about how weird it is
that a 70-year-old man
can't stand still
and always has to
swing his body around
like a first-grader
who has to pee.
And then they'll probably
talk about a bunch of stuff
you don't understand,
like politics
and countries and sanity.
And they're not going to
invite you to dinner.
You know what you're
going to do for dinner?
You're going to eat
a cheeseburger in bed.
Sad!
-In my capacity as...
-Hey, Donald.
It's me, the tiny voice
in the back of your head.
Are you thinking
what I'm thinking?
Because I'm thinking
that Mike Pence
looks a lot more
like a president than you do.
I mean, look at him.
He's killing it right now,
speaking in complete sentences,
turning the page
each time he finishes a page,
not making insane gestures.
He looks like a real president.
And look at you.
You look like a guy
who won a contest
to stand next to a president.
I mean,
he's a complete freak and all,
but at least he can
fake being normal.
How does it feel
to be weirder than Mike Pence?
-Kind Father in heaven --
-Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head,
and I'm going to say the prayer
you wish you could say
right now.
Dear Lord, please let me handle
this elaborate charade
that I'm trapped in.
Please let me open my eyes
and be transported
back to when I was running
casinos and making cameos
in "Home Alone,"
back to a time when I was
disliked but still sort of
a beloved kind of a freak.
But if that can't happen, Lord,
can you please at least
transform this glass of water
in front of me into
a 30-liter bottle of Diet Coke
and a bucket of chicken nuggets?
Because, honestly, Lord, that is
all I really want right now.
Please, Lord,
make everyone disappear
and put chicken nuggets
in front of me.
I'm going to open my eyes, Lord.
I'm going to open my eyes,
and please let that be the case.
Oh, God damn it.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-It's an amazing --
It's an amazing technology.